hello welcome to this video my master
Grandmaster mimosa from Turkey he fork
even cuts cuts needle difficult with the
names so my monster what are you up to
with f5 or not not with their five okay
maybe later I could have done that
earlier actually but ok still happy with
this are you very light heartedly goes
into this position ok in this nice for
white
k to you one I guess threatening also f5
here to make this Bishop look a little
bit weird I asked a g5 though it's still
interesting but ultimately not good I
guess so we can play on the queenside as
well yeah I'll do that
what
why is that also one looks really weird
I have be five and then I have things
going on all these seven okay 24 set the
idea no okay maybe 97 now give it this
is also not bad
still I played this far too quickly i
should have thought for a moment them
about how exactly how exactly i should
punish this so 97 now if i go rookie
seven rookies 17 f8 also looks really
borderline i actually can play group is
seven queen f8 rook takes b7 if it takes
d5 bishop takes King in the koala 24 and
over so the special should be strong
now that works and they also has no good
way to SEC the Queen least I don't see
it
so let's take this yeah context will
probably be checkmate it takes it takes
my night but I also threaten 97 a.m.
maybe rookie age or something like that
24 looks powerful first sight you still
cannot take it out of threatening Knight
f6 next to it
yeah it's not a fun position for black
that's no man moves really now that six
is too strong yeah so here Knight f6
young Queen f6 also should should do the
trick chick chick yeah it should be it
should be enough maybe I have something
more powerful maybe just the Queen to
see three or something black yeah okay
again there's no new moves here I was
very surprised how relaxed he went into
this bad position I mean just very
quickly does this kind of position here
after white against this year I mean he
played this 15 seconds and this is just
strategically not very great for black
just an inferior position long-term
white hands 95 I've got F for the dark
squares a week it's just not a great
position at all and Jim prevent it
anything to deform 94 or 95 the computer
wants to do this already winning yeah
yeah yeah I can do it it wins a 5
basically it was was even stronger the
FF 4 is also also okay it's not as
powerful but why it also has a good
position here yeah but okay then f5 f5
should should be suicide or the other
that loses do this direct game is very
no defense or black's pieces are i
misplaced yeah look b7 he cannot take
jack yeah something like that is made
yeah probably queen bee to us stronger
words well you have no moves here with
black this is this is probably
relatively relatively best but yeah I
can also just take and yeah just just
play for the ending here voice that
actually doesn't act I mean this isn't
the the easiest probably but it should
it should win the ending him yeah it's
it this is a very well known structure
actually this is why I was surprised
that you went for it and this is not
good simply for black if you have this
kind of thing or can get this kind of
thing avoided with black it's it's very
one-sided black has no a serious counter
play at all here and why it has easy
ideas f1 t 195 you simply don't have any
good central control ok guys thanks for
watching